so suffice to say
the the dinner went well and then you
know under the stars there's amazing
starlight and with the you was amazing
we were usually in the background we're
having a good time there was a problem
though we were running out of wood yes
and the story closed i i was i was going
to say so uh we ate like kings and we
drank like kings we uh we learned from
the last camping trip we over stocked on
pretty much
every [ __ ] resource we could think of
our food we did perfectly um no because
we we had we had a bunch of food we
still had a bunch of food
we ate it all yeah well i mean i ate it
while you were if somebody told me i
would have ate it all i would have done
okay no no it's because it's because uh
we ran out of coal yeah and we ran out
of firewood um in in camping outside on
a winter's night we want we ran out of
the one resource that uh is essential
for basically human survival which is
heat it kind of sucked because it was
like oh i'm pretty sure we could still
keep going yeah but i got about 11 pm
and we were we could see them no no i i
i remember it got to about 9 p.m right i
remember because it got to about 9 p.m
and we still wanted to cook some more
food uh but
the the wood just wasn't bringing enough
heat to actually like cook stuff because
it was just charring it and then like
going out right because we needed coal
for it so we decided to stop cooking and
just keep on drinking as as you do you
know just as you keep going with the
liquid dinner yeah um but i remember it
hit about 9 p.m and it started getting a
bit nippy like it started going from
like a comfortable temperature to okay
now i've got to put on this winter
jacket because i'm actually starting to
feel this cold it went down to maybe
around like
two or three degrees maybe something
yeah yeah yeah and then i remember
looking at the firewood and uh we had
someone we had somehow gone through
about 70
of the firewood that we had bought
previously and i remember thinking
[ __ ] how much how much longer is this
going to last us right and i remember it
was at that point that i think we
subconsciously started to like ration it
yeah because like it got colder but i
remember the fires also started to get
colder as well because we weren't
putting in the we weren't putting in the
wood like all willy-nilly anymore we
were like i noticed that like people
were slowly approaching the fire pit
like yeah
yeah but then like got to the point
where i was like oh i need the fire or
i'm actually going to like just die yeah
like our knees were basically in the
fire yeah made me realize how shitty
fires are you know they must have had to
like literally like sleep next to it
because i'm like this [ __ ] is awful yeah
the range of this fire is terrible i
mean errors are terrible insulators
but i was like this is terrible i have
to have basically have my hands in this
thing too probably nature nerf the aoe
or
they fix that patch can they have the
can i have the range increase to fire it
was not yeah i don't know i don't know
what [ __ ] newton was thinking yeah
well what's what's up with that what's
up
it's too powerful because i remember the
fire was like hot enough being close to
it but then my ass was like freezing
[ __ ] cold oh yeah so every so often
like i just have to like put my ass on
top of the fire and then like joey was
just [ __ ] farting non-stop throughout
the entire camping trip and like every
time he put his ass across the fire i'm
like joey please don't fart right now
like i like hold i had held my breath
right because because like i knew like
joey farted i swear to god it would have
used up the rest of the firewood that
was like
the one just
okay first of all when you when you
stand up for a moment right the chair
that you've been warming up for like 30
minutes yeah instantly becomes cold
again it's instantly freezing it sucks
which meant like you didn't want to move
but you had to pee you had to also like
just put stuff on the file yeah it was
awful and also the one thing that
happened where i was like we're gonna
die is that they're trying to light i
think the fire starters with a gas fire
right yeah yeah yeah yeah and then oh
yeah i don't remember that so they tried
to light one of their guys turned on the
gas for this uh this it was basically
like a uh what would you even call it
i was like why the [ __ ] do you have a
blowtorch why don't you just have like
something like a normal life like a
match yeah i don't know but we had a
blow torch and he lit he lit it right he
went to go and point it to start a fire
and the whole blowtorch just went on
fire and i was like uh you might want to
put that out and it's the torch was
catching on fire the gas canister is
right next to you i'm like oh oh oh fire
plus can uh pressure
i was like i'm getting away what the
[ __ ] put it out put it out
yeah the thing is we were like six or
seven because everybody else is kind of
sitting there because oh it's on fire i
i i remember that exact moment
i backed off i was like running away
he's always just sitting there watching
watching not helping yeah
just watching this guy holding this gas
canister on fire
i'm running away and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing run yeah because
like we said i remember my exact pov was
i see it happen like i see him poisoning
it towards the fire he presses the
button and then the gas just leaks on
like to throughout the entire can so the
entire cabin is just covered connor goes
like fight or flight mode he's just like
when that one quiet kid like reached for
his back you know he's [ __ ] half he's
[ __ ] a mile down right i'm not
getting there and like and like me being
like six cans of beers in i'm just like
oh fire
and then it was only after connor's like
guys what the [ __ ] you doing we almost
just died and i'm just like but the fire
it's so pretty yeah
he was like holding that he's so cool
these guys didn't even say anything they
literally sat there like stoners just
watching this yeah i literally like saw
him holding this can of fire and i was
just like
was holding and he was like oh
and then i was giving instructions i was
like all right now turn it off
i remember you running to a distance and
you're like guys what the [ __ ] you doing
what are you doing and i'm just like
oh yeah i should probably uh care for my
life yeah i remember thinking that i'm
just like either run or help
you off should we all right she'll be
all right yeah so uh yeah um don't uh
don't do what we did uh
what did connor did the correct thing
and the power could have helped but also
i would have run around the fire and i
don't know how dangerous this is my
guess my best friend would have been how
about we just leave it on the floor and
then all run yeah
so yeah so that happened and i can't
remember if anything else uh happened
during the campsite i'm pretty sure
these gas canisters have fail safe so
that even if they somehow light on fire
like yeah yeah
i think that's that's that's right so i
don't know
but also i know that you can't heat up a
metal gas canister for very long before
it goes boom yeah that's true that's
true and i'm sure the campsite would
have loved that well we were all right
yeah we're all right we survived i don't
know how are we surprised we didn't end
up on our slash watch people die so
don't worry we're all good all it took
was a few shakes and a bit of a blowing
yeah exactly yeah exactly it wasn't it
wasn't a big fire but it was just like
fire plus gas canister not good yeah
yeah i've ended very badly under any are
there any under any other circumstance i
would have been in the same panic mode
but uh i kind of don't know why i don't
know
i was drunk okay i was very drunk
shockingly calm yeah i was like
just just put it out just put it out
i remember the thought going through my
mind of i should get up and run
but the seats so comfy right now
and it's really cold outside it was it
was like your mom asking you to get out
of bed when it's like about 7 a.m it is
how people do it
is how people die it's i was very stupid
but
at the time it just felt like the right
thing to do in my mind which it wasn't
it wasn't i was very
we could have died multiple times this
is like a double entendre at this time
yeah yeah exactly we almost died we
actually did yeah yeah but uh yeah so
then that happened and then it got to
around like what 11 p.m when we were
11 p.m i could i could have still kept
going yeah me too i wanted to keep yeah
but it got to the point where my entire
life i've been conditioned to think that
no matter how cold it gets i can just
drink more beer and solve the problem um
this was the one time when i was outside
with a thick jacket on and drinking more
beer didn't solve the problem yeah
because i just kept getting colder and
i'm just like what's going on i'm so i
started trying to drink more beer and it
just i just kept getting colder i'm just
like
what is well the thing with alcohol is
that you don't actually get warmer yeah
yeah yeah
i know you just think you're getting
warmer so that just that's just a
testament to how cold it was actually
getting rather than how cold my mind was
thinking it was getting because at a
point i just like wanted to stop
drinking the beer because i would pick
it up and it would just literally be
freezing yeah yeah it was it was yeah
not even nice to drink because of how
cold it was yeah because outside was so
cold would have been great in the summer
oh in the summer
but you know when it's like know zero
degrees outside and you're drinking zero
degree beer it's it's like one of the
few times where you drink a beer and it
gets colder the longer you drink right
like the beers would like because they
were in a crate the beers would start
off at a reasonable amount of coldness
and then they would get like a
reasonable coldness to like ice cooled
like almost frozen yeah also the thing
about ice cold beers that's nice is that
you're not normally drinking it in ice
cold conditions yeah exactly so it warms
up it's a nice temperature and and it's
nice in your body so yeah it's
refreshing but when it's just ice cold
in ice cold conditions you're like it's
totally this feels like a bad idea it
feels like a bad combination yeah
perhaps lukewarm beer would have been
though or hot beer that's why they drink
hot wine in the christmas festival